on prend l'air par haut parleurs les
master classes d'art dramatique comme
dans toute discipline ça débute par un
échauffement avec le travail de la
respiration et de l'articulation
là on a travaillé sur cinq résonateur la
poitrine la bouche le nez la tête et la
nuque et ça c'est très important de
revoir ces bases là et travailler
comprendre comment ça fonctionne parce
que c'est un exercice qui est difficile
et un voilà donc c'est intéressant
est ce qu'un christelle s'est précipité
pour suivre ce cours intensifs de type
actor studio sur le nom du metteur en
scène
yovani médina récompensé par plusieurs
awards
le dramaturge a fait l'aller-retour oui
amidonnerie pour cette master class de
comédiens amateurs sont aussi des
professionnels aussi les amateurs ilan
objective à rendre et en public a
explosé des mentions et c'est tout ce
qui compte
donc c'est un un stage au des
interprètes la présence de yooz vanille
médina on la doit marie laure ducos leur
amitié remonte à une dizaine d'années au
tendon création pour le festival
d'avignon de générosité extraordinaire
et lemm il aime donner il aime partager
et moi c'est un très très grand
pédagogue et en tant que metteur en
scène il peut être très l'urinoir
comédienne j'aime ça j'aime être
torturés comme du chamallow dans tous
les sens sinon ça passait pas c'est pas
intéressant c'est sa loge vanille médina
sera au rendez vous l'an prochain pour
donner nouvelle master classes et peut
être même avant puisque le metteur en
scène est en train de préparer une série
pour netflix qui se déroulera à donnery
si si non oui